what fame did to me like in my 20s and
like having like feeling really
agoraphobic about things so how it
caused some depression and some anxiety
and things like that and
i've dealt with that my whole life i
talked to a ptsd counselor i talked to a
lot of people about this kind of stuff
let's talk about this movie it's called
spree it's out on demand
in theaters uh on august 14th
when you first read this script i mean
what went through
your mind so i was in the middle of
doing the hills
and i had a lot of drama going on
already anyway
and um they were like you know it's
gonna be a couple days for her
i'm like we come on out and we're gonna
get some other great like
people like david arquette so i was like
yeah sure i'm down to clown because
for me acting is my first love obviously
and so
it was nice just to be back on set and
to and weirdly like you know lala and i
we connected in a way that i never
thought we would because she's
from reality tv and she was actually
able to give me some like really
interesting insight into things and like
talk to me about it while we were on set
so we actually had a great time in our
downtime was she giving you advice just
because of like what she's kind of gone
through with vanderpump and you had been
new to the hills at that time
yeah a little bit a little bit you know
it was just funny like the mashup
between like joe keary
and then me and david arquette and then
lala comes in and i was like
you know so she definitely yeah she had
a few words of advice i guess you could
say that
what was it like for you to work with
joe kiri are you a fan of stranger
things um
i am a fan of stranger things um and he
is just such a sweetheart
and like yeah it was really great we
talked a little bit about bonding with
lala but you also worked with frankie
grande so kind of walk me through just
that night
it was great you know i mean we were
definitely up all night in the middle of
the night in the freezing cold but it
was fun
and it was funny frankie's such a
character
and um he's like you know always got
everybody laughing and everybody in a
good mood
so yeah we had a we had a good time a
lot of laughs were hats
this is what we said we wanted an
adventure no london
things that we can put on the ground
let's talk the hills new beginning
season two because there was this report
a while back that you were not going to
be part of it
i talked to heidi and spencer and they
were like she's definitely part of it
so clear the air like what the drama
um yeah i don't know i just i really
like
you know i i'll
there are certain people on the show
that you know you would be surprised i
get along with so well and some that i
don't
um i love them all in their own mad ways
uh there's just like that report that
you're talking about like that had more
to do with like bullying
and that's like something that i really
don't like
stand up for there was some truth to it
that
like this person was going to maybe come
on the show and so like i sort of felt
like i had an egg on my face because i
was like oh well it would be nice if
people would tell us
that because you know there's a history
like when you've been around town for a
long time like
there are certain people who have been
nice to me over the years and then
some other you know not so great female
energy that gets thrown around
and so like hairline yeah and some of
that stuff
so like i was just sort of in the dark
and i didn't really know
that that was even a possibility so i'll
leave it at that
i felt like i was left in the dark all i
can say is that like i take like
the people i work with and like that
kind of bullying aspect and like
the lies like quite seriously but when
you get yourself into reality tv
you know that you're gonna have to put
up with some of that and
you know what like i i seem like very
meek all the time but
there are certain things that do get me
really angry and like we're all really
like
you know i i'll hold my own on that
front and so
i don't care if it's controversial it's
just the way i felt
you know i'm glad that you stood up for
yourself um but you felt like she was
bullying
it's more in the past it's more of like
this is like drama from
over the years and sort of stuff that
maybe didn't get
properly resolved when it should have
and so
like you know that stuff is still like
open wounds and
you know yeah are you are you
gonna be on season two though is that
well we'll see i mean i wonder what's
even going on with them
um in terms of filming i stay in touch
with some of the girls
and i know where everybody is but not
everybody but i know where
a few of the girls are right now and i
know that we're all just kind of doing
our own thing
um yeah let's let's see like when they
can get
production back up and going and what's
gonna happen with them and everything
you know
and who's gonna be on it
watching season one play out what was
that like for you because
you don't come from a reality tv
background it was kind of overwhelming
because they
like i kind of thought that they were
going to be different to the
who they were so there it was like
definitely a bit of a learning curve
um a lot of work i'll tell you that
we were filming a lot you know like
that's what happens when you get
something back up and running i think
and people haven't seen each other for a
long time there's so many different
personalities there they've got to get
involved with each other again they've
got to like you know
yeah they have their own things going on
um
but there were times when we had a lot
of fun and we were genuinely laughing i
think
it's just everything happens for a
reason show started right before
pandemic
and i think you know now it'll be
interesting to see
if everybody has kind of like resolved
any of their
bed and is ready to like kind of deal
with it and face
on truly this time around and like maybe
be like as open and honest
as they can be and like you know maybe
there's some stuff that needs to still
be talked about
yeah um spidey did say we talked to them
probably around like april or may and
they're like we're still filming we
figured out ways to film and quarantine
yeah is that are you guys filming some
of this stuff
or i'm i'm not i'm not i've been orange
meeting and been down here in florida
for quite a while
um i didn't yeah i think
a couple of them are but that's back
yeah
so yes but no not me what would be the
biggest difference between season one
and season two in terms of you and what
we could
potentially see or what you would want
us to see it's just sort of like an
awkward thing between the fact that i
have like a real career
and like then there's this like just
social circle
and so i think the social circle aspect
like the way that it was portraying my
career was kind of frustrating to me
because it's so hard to like
actually get inside an actress's life
and so
i think that like circle of friends
really needs to get sorted out and like
you know it needs to become more
fluid and like you know i think it needs
to be more
fluid and i think you know hopefully
like
the baby bumps of season one are over
and like everybody is like back together
now and like
they kind of have a better idea of who
they are the one thing that i think
would be good is if it was like
just everybody kind of more together
more real less like
you know everybody fronting so much and
like having to be supposed like i would
really like to get everybody to just
like
together as genuine friends could we
potentially see more of your personal
life
play out like is that something that you
would want yeah so i filmed some of that
but like
for the best honestly
[Laughter]
honestly for the best i didn't make it
into the show
um i did have a boyfriend and oh my gosh
yeah yeah so we filmed a little bit but
it's just like
not everybody is like meant for this
kind of stuff
you know are you guys still dating or no
um no are you are you
i'm afraid well that's the thing
quarantine is so weird like
like i feel like everybody wants
somebody during quarantine
and there's a lot of propositioning
going on so that like people aren't so
lonely
but no i'm not really seeing anybody i
think now is like
a good time for people to work on
themselves and to like maybe like
given the end of all of this like we'll
have a clearer idea of where we all
stand
because you know my ex is quarantining
in australia i was dating somebody in
l.a
like it's all very dramatic but for
right now i think that
concentrating on myself is probably the
best yeah
well you are a catch so i get why
there's propositions happening
what are you looking for in a
relationship so my thing now is to try
to look for somebody who
always makes me laugh because that's 100
important especially in our business
is like loyal is not going to stab you
in the back because
that's the other thing that you always
get around you know
people who don't genuinely want to be
with you for the right reasons
i want somebody who's like just really
grounded now at this point
you know i've dated some interesting
characters in the past and like all for
federers
those are my 20s i'm looking for
somebody who's like
got more qualities than that now in
terms of like
long time do you have a message to your
fans right now anything you want to tell
them
say to them i know this these are really
weird times
and um i've spoken before about feeling
like
you know really detached and like what
fame did to me like in my 20s and like
having
like feeling really agoraphobic about
things and not and these are strange
times for everyone and i see a lot of
those traits in
like young people now and people like
acting out
and going through tough times because of
this quarantine and what's going on
so i would just say like everybody
should stick
to it stick to the things that you love
the things that make you happy
i'm sorry that you felt like that about
fame in your 20s like that makes me so
sad
because i mean no i mean i did used to
though and i've spoken about
like you know how it caused some
depression and some anxiety and things
like that and i've
dealt with that my whole life and so i
like to be quite open about it
i'm like on a couple of like i do a lot
of work with people who i talk to a ptsd
counselor i talk to a lot of people
about this kind of stuff and you know i
think it's
all about being honest about the way
that you feel about things and that's
how
you heal and so it's like when you're
trying to hide things
that that it gets worse it's hard to
confront things head on but
yeah it's all about real family and
about friends